hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't [ __ ] your pants if
you don't know about this game it's a
game about not [ __ ] your pants and
if you don't know any male right now
know more about this game it's made by
the developers of rogue legacy before
they made that good game and if you
don't know about that game well played
it's really fun and also it's like 5 in
the mornings probably like 5:30 it's
5:30 in the morning right now I've got
nothing better to do and stay up and
show you guys about a game that's about
[ __ ] your pants so why don't we play
oh [ __ ] I need to click into the text
box because it's like the olden days of
Dass you gotta type in what you wanted
to do and I wanna play so this is like
this was this Larry I think is I don't
think even has a name but he really
really needs to take a [ __ ] and you only
got a certain amount of time to do it
and there's a door that leads to a
bathroom now I know about this game back
when it came out originally on
Newgrounds and it was just a lot of fun
to play I didn't get through all over
the game when I played it but I did
manage to beat the game as hard as that
may seem I did do that you're running
out of time you need to find a way to
reduce pressure in your gut
how bout I fart uh I farted too hard and
[ __ ] my pants
maybe next time you shouldn't push it so
hard is that what she said probably not
yeah there's some things I need to
remember because it's been a while since
I play this game yeah fart really hard I
don't know how to fart really hard well
that's a fundamental skill fart not hard
goddamnit fart soft yeah sweet relief a
gaming border ok so the main objective
of the game is the open door whole open
door I remember it being open door oh my
god hold or ariel sit on toilet [ __ ]
oh I forgot to take my pants up hang on
I'll get back to it in a second
oh god damn it pulled door take off
hands sit you need to let it sit on
toilet [ __ ] I'm officially the best oh
god I just realized what I'm doing I'm
doing you a stupid game about not
[ __ ] your pants Oh what am i doing
where did my life go so right am i right
okay so anyway the next thing that I
need to do is how I need to get all the
rest of these awards now I didn't do
this before I don't think okay you know
what I'm just gonna explore bet to see
what Larry here can do okay take off
weight off pants I thought that might do
something because it did with the game
wanted me to do which was just not [ __ ]
my pants [ __ ] out mouth okay barf sleep
I'm not reading it see you guys will
wring the text your vision fades in you
hear soft you [ __ ] your pants you suck
wait what happened to my achievements
damn it oh god my words like oh no wait
I got and I can't believe I'm putting so
much thought into it I don't know how to
get all these achievements ah sit on
toilet damn it there's so many things
that I could do but okay maybe there's
more I can't remember I might look up a
walkthrough for this sumbitch I'm gonna
look up a walkthrough for the kid about
not [ __ ] your pants oh god damn Oh
[Music]
what happened okay okay hang on wait
there's something here play I just look
at pants check your pockets you find
some pills for stomach relief it says
take 45 seconds to start working so far
it's soft
II take pills yes they will and in the
meantime I'm just gonna look up more
walk through stuff okay this game sucks
this game is stupid I think that was all
of them hang on wait wait wait wait and
oh oh [ __ ] the game hasn't started yet
but you can help yourself this is
telling everybody are you proud of me
yet
ma and everyone else
watching God how many people are
watching this crap tired alright so I
hope you enjoyed this video it was a lot
of fun to make and it was I pologize for
recording so late I got caught up with
other crap and then other stuff happened
I don't know I have no excuses
why later on today at noon Pacific's
time 3 p.m. Eastern Time whatever other
time it is it's gonna be a special video
that comes out a really important
animation that is coming out that a lot
of people have been dying for spooky
animation if you know what I mean so
stay tuned for that video if you want to
see something of just a little just a
little more quality than what you just
saw so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]
so in this lake house in upstate New
York managing the Catskills Catskills
Catskills